what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be doing a rap
reaction
to all right i hope i'm saying this
right
the real g money industry
official music video young boy
never broke again response don't know
any of the backstory have no idea what's
going on
but i'm about to react to it
all right stop that [ __ ] case this [ __ ]
[ __ ] what
dumb
[ __ ] man
[Music]
i believe he's saying i heard a bank
account
and something about checks so i think
he's talking about how much money he had
[ __ ] never did a [ __ ] [ __ ]
don't know why this [ __ ] tripping never
little [ __ ]
staying to all of my tips switched
[Music]
okay so he's saying that he's in a gang
everyone else is lame sneak dissing on
them songs
[Music]
it sounds like he had a friend betray
him
it sounds like he's upset it sounds like
he's hurt honestly
you know i he's got some pent up
frustration for your cousin
[Music]
okay at least he's saying i can't kill
you that's a good message like
a lot of the songs i've reacted to
there's a lot of
violence you know and it's a good thing
that he's saying i won't kill you
why the [ __ ] [ __ ] you know me never
did nothing
away before the wrath now i fit the
ground up in jury
but for what though everything
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so i think trippin it means like
it's hard to explain like there's a
problem and you really shouldn't be like
tripping over it but you are
here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay so he's saying he can't mess with a
girl
who is broke that's understandable if
he's got money
he expects his woman to have money
[Music]
[Music]
okay so he talked about a sneak diss and
he says come to me directly
so he's saying if you got something to
say say it to my face
now personally a lot of people annoy me
am i going to go up to every single
person that annoys me
and say it to their face hell
no i'm not rude
i'm a sneak disser i am
sue me i ain't with you wrestling i
don't wanna rap beef with you
that ain't gives you in the industry and
i'm still in the streets
okay i can't believe that song has this
many views like it was cool but i've
bopped my head
to way better songs uh
i'm sorry man four out of ten
four out of ten don't don't sue me all
right
let me know in the comments you agree
disagree please subscribe
i don't want to beg but i will
i will i'll do it please please
subscribe
anyways i'm uh i'm gonna talk to you
guys next time
maybe